Hello everyone and again welcome to
lecture six of CME295.
Uh so today is actually an exciting day
because we're going to uh cover a topic
that has been trending over the past
year or so which is LLM reasoning.
And it's actually a good segue compared
to what we talked last time which was uh
preference tuning because a lot of the
methods that we used in lecture five are
going to be the ones that we'll be using
as kind of the foundations for this
lecture.
So before we start as usual we're going
to uh just cover quickly what we saw in
the last lecture.
So if you remember lecture four and
lecture five were all about learning how
we can train a model. So in lecture four
we saw the first part which was the
pre-training part which is the most
compute intensive step where we
basically teach the model the structure
of text the structure of codes and we do
this very large large scale training.
So at the end of this first step which
is the pre-training we get a model that
knows about code that knows about
language but it only knows how to
autocomplete a sequence and so that's
why we also saw uh the second step which
was the finetuning step where we take
our pre-trained model and we try to make
it useful.
So one use case that we saw was for
instance uh you know an assistant. So we
tried to tune it in a way that it can
respond to questions and so here we have
uh this work of preparing the SFT data
which which is what we call the SFT data
uh which is a high quality created data
set that we can use to teach our model
on how to behave. So at the end of this
second step we have our model that is
tuned for a specific task which can be
um responding to queries. And then last
lecture we saw this third step
which was the preference tuning step.
And here the goal is to align our model
with human preferences.
So we saw in particular RHF which was a
common method to do that and we saw that
there was two steps to it. So there was
the first part learning to distinguish
good from bad using human preference
data
and then there was this second step
which was this RL stage which is going
to be useful today.
So in particular, if you remember, we
had drawn a comparison between the RL
setup that you may be familiar with uh
outside of this class where we have uh
an agent that is interacting with the
environment
and the way that it interact with it is
that given a given a state that it is
in, it can take an action following ing
a policy
which is nothing else than just a
probability distribution over actions.
So given
a state our agent can take an action
following this policy and at the result
of this it receives some reward.
And we saw last lecture that we have
this nice comparison between the
traditional RL setup and the LLM setup.
And so here our quote unquote agent is
just simply the LLM.
Um the environment that it interacts
with is just the set of tokens that it
can predict over.
So given an input that it has received
so far,
it can predict what the next token could
be which is the action and it does that
using the probability distribution
that is the result of uh I guess the LM
prediction. And we saw that we can
obtain human preferences
for each completion.
So you have a prompt, you have a
completion and you get those human
preferences.
And this is the one that you then use in
order to tune the LLM because here this
step is about aligning the model with
human preferences. And here the human
preferences is encapsulated in the
reward.
And so we saw that the loss function
during the RL stage is composed of two
parts.
So the first part is this advantage
maximization
and we saw that that advantage was based
on the rewards uh and it has some
baseline to just reduce the variance of
the gradient. Uh so we have that part
but we also saw
another part
which was that we don't want our model
to deviate too much from either the
previous iteration. So we don't want the
model to change too much from iteration
to iteration.
But we also don't want our model to
change too much compared to our initial
model like our base model. And here it's
the SFT model. And the reason why we
don't want to change too much is because
our model has already learned a lot.
It's already quite performant in what it
does. And what we want is to just align
it with human preferences which is not
something for which we want the model to
change completely.
And I think that was the part that um I
think was a little bit scary which was
the actual loss functions. So if you
remember the main algorithm that is
typically used in the RHF setting is PO
which stands for proximal policy
optimization
and there is this one variant that's
called PO clip
which is such that it clips the updates
from one iteration to another. So here
if you remember R is actually not the
reward it is the ratio and I know it's a
confusing confusing notation.
So it's the ratio between the current
policy and the old policy and the old
policy here is the policy that is at the
previous RL iteration.
So what we do is that we have a clipping
mechanism
such that the ratio cannot go beyond
some certain thresholds
such that we do not want to incentivize
the model to make too big of an update.
And we saw another variant of PO which
is called PPO kale penalty.
And this variant
uses the kale divergence
to penalize the model from changing too
much.
So if you remember in the original PO
paper uh you we used the old
quoteunquote old version of the model
which is the one at the previous RL
iteration.
But in modernday RHF training, this
scale divergence is typically applied to
the base model, which is the SFT model.
So I guess long story short is we have
these two PO variants that were variants
that were introduced in the original PO
paper.
But in modernday RLF training, we
typically have some combination, some
mix of these two loss functions.
Cool.
So, up until now, we've seen what I want
to call vanilla LLMs, which are LLMs
that take something as an input, let's
say a prompt, and just respond with some
answer.
And so those vanilla LLMs, they have a
lot of strength that we can enjoy. So,
first of all, we had seen that those
LLMs, they know a lot about structure of
the text. They know a lot about codes.
So in particular, if you want to debug
your code, I guess they're great to find
where the error is. They are great to
generate codes. They're also great to
generate, I don't know, essays or poems.
They're really, really good at that.
But I do want to call out some
weaknesses.
So the first, I guess, weakness that I
want to call out in these vanilla LLMs
is that they have quote unquote limited
resoning.
So typically if you kind of have it have
uh some sophisticated let's say math
problem it will not really um kind of
come up with I guess the solution
because maybe it will like uh get lost
in the in the way um because up until
now our model has been really trained to
I guess given a prompt respond to it
using the kind of next token prediction.
So I guess here there is not like really
a big reason why it would be able to
solve I guess complicated problems. So I
guess that is one.
So second weakness is that the LLM that
we have has been pre-trained on a huge
amount of data which is static
meaning that the knowledge that the LLM
has acquired is bound to the cutoff date
what we call the cutoff dates at which
we cut and formed our pre-training data.
So I know a few days ago we had an
election. So if let's say we trained our
LLM based on data before the election
and let's say today we ask it okay who
is the I don't know elected official of
let's say X it will not be able to
answer us because it does not have
access to knowledge after that date.
So a third weakness is so far it's uh
all talk no action. So you just uh
prompt your LLM but I guess if you want
to let's say I don't know um like place
an order or I don't know do some action
you just cannot do it.
And then I guess the last weakness which
by the way is not an exhaustive list is
contrary to traditional NLP models LLMs
they generate free form text
and it's hard to evaluate them in the
framework that we I mean by we is the ML
community has adopted up until a few
years ago. So if you're familiar with
it, let's suppose if you worked in the
translation world, you would use
rulebased metrics like blur or for
summarization rouge to evaluate your
outputs. But then here LLMs, they can
really do more than just that. So it's
very hard to evaluate them.
So what I want to say is that this is
let's say a subset of all the weaknesses
that LMS can have. And the last three
are going to be topics that we will
cover in the next lecture and in the
lecture eight.
And as I mentioned before, the focus of
today is reasoning. So we'll see how we
can improve the way our LLM reasons.
Cool. And again, um this is a topic
that's been very new and by new I mean
roughly a year. So almost everything
that we will see is uh either from 2024
or 2025.
And I guess we're lucky because now we
have kind of enough hindsight to just
know which piece is more important than
other things. And so the goal for today
is going to be to know what reasoning
models are.
And the second big goal is to know how
they are trained.
So hopefully at the end of this lecture
if you have a good answer to these two
questions that means that we have done a
good job.
Okay. So let's start with reasoning
models. What are they? Well to answer
this question we first need to I guess
define what reasoning is. And the bad
news here is there's not a commonly
agreed upon definition out there of what
reasoning is. So I will try to define it
um I guess to the best of my ability. So
here we define reasoning as the ability
to solve a problem.
And here by problem we typically think
more of math problems or let's say
coding problems.
But hopefully these abilities can also
kind of spread to other fields as well.
And in order to solve this problem,
we typically need a multi-step reasoning
process. like a little bit like you when
you take an exam when you have a
question that's not trivial you
typically break that down into several
steps and then kind of go through them
and then come to the final answer. So I
guess the idea is problems that are
reasoning problems they would have some
pattern of that.
So to illustrate this let's uh just make
sure we're all kind of thinking the
same. So a non-reasoning question would
be something like what is the course
code of Stanford's transformers and LM
class. So this one know it's a knowledge
thing. Everyone knows it's CME 295.
But then um as opposed to that in
contrast to that a reasoning based
question would be maybe a math question.
So for instance let's suppose we have a
bear that was born in 2020. How old is
that bear now in 2025? So that that
would be the kind of question that we're
looking at. Of course, this is super
easy. Can think of like something
that's, you know, much harder than that
and this would qualify.
Cool. Okay. So now that we know a little
bit what reasoning is, now we're going
to look at how we can I guess obtain a
model that can deal with these kinds of
prompts.
So the core idea here is to leverage a
concept we saw earlier in the class.
So I'm not sure if you remember but back
in lecture maybe two or three we saw a
technique called chain of thought.
So who remembers what chain of thought
is?
Yeah. Yes. Do you want to say what what
that is?
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. So the answer is
you know thinking in steps be instead of
just giving just a blanket answer. So
great great answer. So here just to
illustrate. Yeah.
Yep.
>> Oh yeah, great point. So the question is
uh for some questions you need to have
some element of context. So for instance
here you need for your LLM to know that
this year I don't know today's November
7th 2025. So yes, great points. Um so
there are two parts of that for that
specific question. So typically LLMs
they have a something that that we call
preamble. So something that tells you
about some context uh and typically the
date is something that we put in the
preamble. So for this very specific case
the date would be uh an information that
would already be uh I guess available to
the LM. But for some other problems, you
can very well have information or
context that you do not have. And um in
lecture 7, we will see how we can uh
kind of fetch that. And it's definitely
something that that will be very useful.
Um but for the sake of today, we will
consider this more as being an extension
of reasoning models as opposed to
something that is foundational to how
they work. But we'll respond to to this
part I guess next lecture.
Cool. And so here we were about to
illustrate what a chain of thought look
like. And so here um instead of having
as you mentioned just a blanket answer
what we want is to explain also the
reasoning.
So the way Chenn thought did that was by
having some in context learning examples
that explicited the reasoning
to encourage the model to also do that
before providing the answer.
So that's the rough it's not a rough
idea it's the the idea behind chain of
dots.
And here what we want to do is to do
that but at a much larger scale.
So I just want to build an intuition as
to why this may help us.
So LLMs they're basically trained with
this next token prediction objective.
And so the way they respond to questions
that we ask is typically to sound
plausible
in a way to maximize or optimize for the
probability of the tokens that you want
to generate to happen.
So if you have a very hard problem that
you're presenting to the LLM,
there are very few chances that that
problem appeared in the training sets.
And so here the idea is to have the LLM
decompose the problem into tractable
ones
and then rely on the patterns that it
has seen during training to solve all
these more tractable problems. And it's
a little bit like uh you or when we were
students, right? Like when we give you a
problem, you try to kind of link it back
to something that you know that you have
seen at training time like during your
studying
to solve them in order to find the
answer.
So I guess that's the intuition. Um I
guess another reason that you can think
of is when you let the LLM generate more
tokens,
you're just giving it more compute. If
you think about it,
because at each generation step, you
have this whole forward path pass.
And when you do that more, you just give
it more compute.
And we will see there is a term that is
dubbed compute budgets,
which is I guess the budget that you
want your L&M to have to generate your
response that we will see later on. Uh
but yeah, so that also plays a role.
So, is everyone uh clear on the overall
idea of what the reasoning model is?
Yeah.
Okay. Perfect. So, just to make sure
again that we're all clear on this. So,
up until now, we had quote unquote
vanilla LLMs
that had some prompt, some question as
input, and they were responding with
something as output.
And in our case what we want is given a
question as input
we don't want to directly generate an
answer we first want to think and here I
guess we think by first outputting a
reasoning chain
and then we provide the answer.
So here the LLM output is not just the
answer, it's the reasoning
plus the answer.
And I guess yeah, I was saying that this
uh topic has been very hot and trendy
for the past year. So this is a little
bit of a preview of the timeline of
reasoning models. Um so reasoning itself
is a topic that has been studied for
more than a year but reasoning models
have started popping out
starting from OpenAI's release of 01
preview and this one was uh September of
and then after that uh you basically
have everyone just wondering how OpenAI
did it and so you had you know all this
AI labs trying to kind of see what we
can do to um I guess increase the
reasoning abilities of the model. So you
would have everyone working on this and
then you had uh Google's Gemini 2.0
uh flash thinking that was I think
released in December
and then starting in 2025
uh there was this uh DeepSync R1 paper
that was published in January which made
a lot of noise because what they were
able to do was to match OpenAI's
reasoning ability performance
with a method that they were actually
you know describing ing in their paper.
So that was a big moment January 2025
and then after that you know all these
other models also had uh reasoning
abilities added. So you had um some
models from XAI from anthropic with
clouds and then from uh other labs as
well also from um uh Mistral. So this
timeline is not exhaustive but it's just
to show you I guess how recent these
models are and I guess one thing to have
in mind is it basically started at the
end of 2024.
Cool. So I know a lot of you if not all
of you are using uh LLM every day as you
know chatbots like let's say chat GPT or
Gemini and so I want you to know when
the model that you're interacting with
is a reasoning model. So I have a
question for you.
I was having a discussion with Chad GPT
the other day and I was wondering is
this
using a reasoning model
because guess uh what do you think if
you kind of stare at the screenshots?
Yeah. Why?
Right. Exactly. So the key word here is
thinking. Actually they they put it
everywhere. But um when these UIs show
you the thinking process
so what they do is actually so they
don't show you actually the full
reasoning process and we're going to see
why. But they tell you that they spend
time thinking
and that time thinking is actually the
time that is needed to produce the
reasoning chain that can be I guess more
or less something that takes time. Uh
and so for instance for chip you have
this uh thinking that you can also
change from standard to extended etc.
And you have this for other models as
well.
And in particular, the thought that you
the quote unquote thought summary that
you see is not the raw reasoning chain.
It's a summary of it.
And the reason why they do that, I mean,
I'm hypothetizing is one because the raw
chain maybe may not be something that is
fully intelligible from a human
standpoint.
Second is because maybe you as a user
you don't want to read pages and pages.
And then third, this is going to be what
we see. But
if you have the reasoning chains, if you
have the reasoning chain, you can
maybe uh train a model that you know is
trained on these chains. So it can
basically mimic those abilities as well.
So this may be the reason the reasons
why you would typically not see the raw
chain
and when it comes to pricing so we saw
that the output of reasoning models are
not only the answer but also the
reasoning itself and so you will see in
I guess all of these APIs that you're
actually getting charged for it so
you're not necessarily getting all the
reasoning chain but uh if you look at
the the ducks there's always I guess a
sentence or two uh I guess that
specifies that you're actually being
charged for output tokens and those
output tokens they also include
reasoning tokens so I think that's also
a good thing to know
um and I guess from a user standpoint
this also gives an incentive to have the
maximum imum reasoning ability for a
minimum amount of reasoning token
because you don't want to pay a lot,
right? So, we're going to see later on
how we can deal with that, but this is
just one thing that's good to note.
Cool. So, we talked about what reasoning
was or at least tentative definition. We
saw I guess the core idea behind
reasoning models. So now we're going to
talk about some of the benchmarks that
people use to quantify reasoning
abilities.
So the first one as I previously
mentioned is about assessing the coding
abilities.
And so here the goal is typically to
solve a coding problem or to fix a bug.
So you typically have the following
setup.
So given a problem,
you want to produce a solution
that
is able to pass test cases.
So if you have a solution that you that
passes all test cases, then you have a
solution that works.
And this is our way of verifying that
a response that was generated is
actually a correct one.
So that's for coding.
Um okay so just giving you an overview
of the kinds of benchmarks that are out
there. So we have uh human eval which is
uh the screenshots here which I believe
is a set of 100 something coding
problems that were human written which
is why it's called human evil. But you
have then code forces uh which is coming
from a website of competitive
programming that some of you may know
and there is also swbench uh which is I
believe a set of problems that were
derived from GitHub issues. So these are
like real practical problems. So you
will see that these reasoning models
in the reports they typically have
results along these benchmarks.
So this is for coding.
Now for math
the goal is to you know solve a problem
and the way it works here is given a
problem you want the answer and of
course you're letting your model you
know generate some reasoning.
And so here what you would do to verify
that your solution works is by parsing
the answer
like like so and then comparing it with
some ground truth.
So here you can really know if the
answer that your model is producing is
true by comparing the two.
So you will ask me okay how do you parse
that? So you can force your model and by
force I mean in the prompt to output the
answer in a way that can be parsible.
Sometimes people they just put it in
some box in the box brackets. So there's
a number of different ways to do that
and uh this is uh how the problems look
like. So uh you have some problem and
then you can let your model uh you know
generate some reasoning chain along with
the answer and then you have the answer
here that you can compare to. Um so I
just want to add that um the kinds of
benchmarks that are out there are based
typically on problems that are actually
not that trivial. So a name that you
will see a lot is AIM.
So I'm not sure if you're familiar with
it. It's um a math exam to qualify for
the US math olympiads.
Um so there is a bunch of models that um
I guess um quantify their performance
based on that. There's also GSM 8K which
is a grade school kind of math problem.
And I guess now your question maybe okay
it's great we have all these benchmarks
but what is the metric that you will use
to quantify that what you're doing is
good or not
and so there is one metric that you will
see a lot and we're going to see that
right now because it's not that obvious.
So that metric is called pass at K.
So pass at K is by definition a metric
that tries to estimate the probability
that at least one of K attempts
succeeds.
So here what we're saying is let's
suppose we're I don't know having some
coding problem. We tell our model to
generate K answers
and pass at K is the probability that at
least one of these K answers
passes
the tests.
Does that make sense?
So, by the way, why would you have pass
at K? Like why why would that make
sense?
Okay, so it's not super trivial. Um, so
you may have use cases where
you can afford to spend more time
to generate more answers.
If you know that you will get more
chances to get it right,
then you can spend more time to generate
more answers so that you can can have
like the right one.
So in a problem like coding,
the good thing is you can check whether
your answer is correct or not.
And so here the idea is if you are in
cases where you can afford to generate
not just one answer but multiple answers
then it may be worth it to just spend
more time spend more compute to generate
more answers if it means that the
probability of getting it right in one
of them is going to be higher.
So there is one technique that we saw
last lecture that
is kind of familiar with this best of n.
Do you remember?
Yeah roughly. Okay. So best of n is this
method that we saw last last week which
was you generate n answers and you use
your reward model to score everything
and you take the best best of all of
them. So here you can think of it as
being kind of the same
just that we do not have a reward model.
We have a deterministic verifiable way
of checking whether something is
correct.
So it's very similar to that.
And okay so now we're going to spend
just a few minutes just um aligning our
understanding on
um how we can estimate such a quantity.
Yep.
That's a great question. So question is
uh do you uh choose a particular
temperature? So I have a slide on that.
So I I'll just hold your question for a
few slides. Cool. Wait. By the way, if
there is any other questions uh you know
happy to Is there any other questions on
this?
Everyone is super clear. Okay. Cool. So
what we want to do here is to estimate
this probability.
But you may tell me okay just generate k
attempts and just count the number of uh
of the attempts that are um correct to
estimate that.
But the problem is if you only do this k
times your estimate can be very noisy
because by pure chance I don't know you
may have uh one instance that has I
don't know three correct out of five and
the other one one. So you want to have
an estimate that doesn't have that much
variance. So what you do is you
typically generate not k but n answers
and out of these n answers
you are going to have c of them that are
going to be successful and then n minus
c that are not going to be successful.
And the question here that you ask
yourself
is out of these n attempts
you want to quantify
your the probability of having at least
one out of k attempts that is right. So
the question here if you have those n
observations
if you were to select let's say k
what is the probability of having at
least one of those k passing?
That's the question.
So we're short on time. Uh I'm going to
actually uh derive that right now. Um,
and the reason why I want to do that is
because the answer is not necessarily
trivial and I don't want you to be uh
too uh you know uh surprised of how how
it looks like without uh kind of knowing
where it comes from.
So we're going to derive that. So we
want to derive the probability that at
least one attempt out of k that we
select out of these n samples
is correct.
So in order to do that I'm just going to
write that down. So pass k. So we want
the estimate for that.
So, it's going to be the probability
that at least one attempt
out of K
is correct.
So if you've done some probability there
is like a very common trick which is if
you have a probability of at least one
it's one minus the probability of having
all of them being incorrect.
Do you all know that trick? Okay. So
we're going to use that trick. So it's
going to be one
minus the probability
of having all
k attempts
uh incorrect.
So far so good. Yeah. Okay. So now we're
going to try to quantify this
probability.
So what is the probability of you
finding
an unsuccessful attempt among this n?
You have n minus c unsuccessful.
you have n observations
is going to be
n minus c
over n.
Right? So it's your first it's your
first unsuccessful attempt.
So now what is the probability that you
have another unsuccessful attempt
knowing this one?
So you have n minus c minus one other
unsuccessful attempts
over
n minus one because you already took one
and you continue that k times
n - c - k + 1
over n - k + 1.
Does everyone agree with me?
So here we are quantifying the
probability that if we take k
samples randomly among these n that all
k1s are incorrect.
So here
we compute this by computing the
probability that the first attempt is
incorrect and then the second one is
incorrect knowing that the first one was
incorrect and so on which we have for
which we have this uh formula.
So if you uh saw that in probability
class, it's basically the same as
sampling without replacement.
And now the nice thing with this is that
you can express that with a nice
mathematical notation. So for people who
know
so n choose k
is equal to factorial n
factorial k
factorial n minus k. So this is by
definition of what this quantity is
about. So we're going to use that here.
So here we have
a series of products. So here we can
express that as factorial over another
factorial. So here it's factorial n
minus c
over factorial
n minus c minus k.
And then this quantity we can also
express express that with factorials.
So it's factorial n and then numerator
is factorial n minus k.
Everyone agrees with the math here.
I take that as a yes.
And so here we're going to somehow
pop the expression above up. So it's
going to be equal to 1 minus
um so
n minus c factorial over n - c minus k
factorial
and then k factorial
and then here we're going to say it's
this one
k factorial k factorial
over n factorial. So here I did a a
trick. What I did was
I basically multiplied the numerator and
the denominator by k factorial.
And so here I have 1
minus. So this is
n minus c over
n. So n minus c choose sorry n minus c
choose k
over
n
choose k.
So this
this is our estimate
of pass at k.
Does everyone agree?
Yeah.
Okay.
So, the reason why I derived it is uh
because that this formula can be a
little bit daunting to look at, but it's
actually quite um natural because it's
only using some sampling without
replacement
um considerations.
And so, you will see in papers that
people have this pass K metric. So if
you were to compute it, this would be
the formula to use.
Cool. And uh special K of pass at K is
pass at one
and pass at one is defined as the
probability of a single attempt
succeeding.
So this is something that is more uh
something that you you commonly know. Uh
so if suppose you have a model that
produces an answer what is the
probability that is correct.
So if you replace K with one you will
see that this formula will simplify a
lot and it will be just a proportion of
successful attempts which also makes
sense just intuitively.
Cool. Everyone clear with this?
Yeah.
Great. Um so now to your question um so
what do you do with the temperature and
you're exactly right
when you generate these solutions
multiple times something that will
influence your results is how diverse
the solutions that you will generate
will be and this is something that you
indeed
use the temperature for.
Now, okay. So, what is the relationship
between temperature and pass K? Do do we
want low temperature? Do we want a high
temperature? Or do we want something in
the in between?
Well, if you take a very low
temperature,
you know that your solutions will be
good, but they will not be diverse.
So if you increase the number of number
of samples that you generate that
quantity would not change which is seen
with uh this graph with the t equal to0
it doesn't change but then when you have
t equal to 0.2 two. Now it increases
because you have some diversity.
But if you increase this temperature too
much,
then you will have the diversity that
you want, but they will also harm the
performance of your predictions because
maybe the tokens that were not that
likely would become likely. And so here
on the opposite side, we have I don't
know t= 1.2 two here which is extreme in
this in this example which is not the
best. So I guess to respond to you uh
typical temperature choice would be
something that is not too large not too
small and I believe in this example is t
equal to8
that I think produces the best results
towards the bigger samples but then here
I guess it's not clear maybe 04
so that's why you will see that in
papers
people always specify the temperature
that they choose to produce the
benchmark results.
So that's why it's uh good to have have
that in mind.
Cool. So these are the main metrics that
people use but not the only ones.
There's another one that you may see
which is called consensus at K
which is the answer that is coming from
the highest number of times that the
answer appears among your generations
and you can think of the
self-consistency technique as being very
related to that.
Um so yes so you may see that and then
the other metrics that you will see in
those benchmarks are typically the ones
that you're familiar with uh like
accuracy exact match and so on.
Cool. Okay. I took a lot of time on this
first part. I think I need to go a bit
faster. But does that roughly make sense
so far?
Yeah. Okay. So right now I hope you know
what a reasoning model is. So now we're
going to go into the most interesting
part of the lecture which is how can we
build such a reasoning model. So we know
we want our reasoning model to produce a
reasoning chain but right now we don't
really know how to do that at scale
and this is going to be the main focus
in this part. So here the idea is to
somehow incentivize the model to produce
a chain of thought a reasoning chain
before answering.
So the problem with that is that
reasoning chains writing is a very tough
task especially for I guess long
reasoning long reasoning chains
and for that let's suppose if we were to
go look into our toolbox of the
techniques we have learned so far you
know maybe we can think okay we can use
SFT to do that but the problem with SFT
is you need high quality data and in
particular you would need to write all
these reasoning chains.
Let's suppose you do not have these
reasoning chains. So how do you do that?
You would typically write them from
scratch but that is very hard.
So that's one uh I guess one vote one
vote to not do SFT if we don't have any
reasoning chains.
So the second reason here is or the
second fact is that the way the model
reasons may be different from the way we
reason
and for that
maybe a human written human written
reasoning may not be the best way to
teach the model on how to reason.
So that's the second fact which is uh
going against having some human written
human written reasoning chains as SFT
data.
And then the third fact that I want to
say is we just saw that these reasoning
tasks they have a very natural
rewards which is actually verifiable.
So for coding you know if your thing
works if it passes some test cases if it
compiles
and for math you know if it works if the
answer is the same as your ground truth.
So naturally you do have a reward
signal.
So we saw there's a reward signal sft is
not the great way to start from scratch.
Well what do you do? Well, let's uh try
RL then. And the good thing is last week
we saw how RL works in the case of LLMs.
So I guess that's great timing.
So how would we do that?
So just as a reminder, we want to teach
our model to solve these more
complicated problems and we also want to
teach it to reason before.
So in order to do that, we first want to
have a reward
that checks whether the reasoning chain
is there.
So here you can do that by simply
checking whether the model has produced
a reasoning chain and you can check that
by checking the presence let's say of
the think start and end token
that you can instruct your model to use
to insert its reasoning chain.
And then the second reward that you want
to have is to check that the solution
that it produced actually works. And so
here as we mentioned this is something
that you can actually do for the
benchmarks that we we care about. So for
code you would check that it works for
all cases. For math you would just
verify with respect to the you know
answer being the same as the ground
truth. So we also have that.
So in summary, we will run RL and we
will run RL using a reward that is a
combination of checking whether the
think tokens are here are here
and that the end result is correct. And
we saw that both of them we can do this
easily. No need for a model.
Cool. So let's suppose you do that.
Let's suppose you you do RL on such
rewards.
Well the nice thing that you see is if
you plot the performance of the model
with respect to one of those benchmarks
that I mentioned. So here it's aim. So
if you remember it's the math benchmark.
You see that as you
perform your RL steps,
the performance of the model on those
benchmarks, they actually increase and
they actually increase quite
significantly.
So the graph here is actually coming
from uh the training of deepseek R1
actually R10 here which we will see a
little bit more in detail with Shervin
how it actually works. But you can see
that if you incentivize the model to
think and produce the right answer, it
can actually learn quite meaningfully
only with these two like verifiable
rewards.
Cool. But now you may wonder, okay,
let's suppose I'm teaching my model to
think. Well, not all prompts are equal,
right? like there are some prompts that
do not need the model to think too much
as opposed to other prompts which would
need a little bit of thinking.
So there's been a lot of uh I guess work
happening in the the community as to how
to control the amount of thinking that
the model does.
So you have things like dynamic uh
budget that you will see out there you
know uh how can we make sure that the
model does not overthink on overthink on
questions that do not need too much
thinking. So for this you can have
something like a quick classifier let's
say uh that runs on the prompt and tells
you whether it's something that is kind
of a highinking kind of problem or a
lowinking one. uh but this is more of an
open problem but this can be one
solution.
So the second one is
those LLMs
they have a limited context window.
So when the LLM thinks
it needs to also be aware of how much
context length is left.
It cannot think too much also because of
that limitation.
So you need to also have that context
awareness.
Uh so there has been some work to also
force the model to either think more or
stop. So there is this term budget
forcing uh that I think was introduced
in this paper uh S1. So the idea here is
if you want your model to continue
thinking, you're going to introduce some
tokens midway to force it to think more.
And such tokens are for instance uh
weights. I think there's another
solution. Um so actually it's a slide
that I have not really talked about. Um
so if you look at this reasoning chain
sometimes the model will output
something like oh wait wait wait uh I
think I found something else and
typically the model would go again on
another uh kind of reasoning path and
this can be one way to incentivize your
model to think more.
Uh or another term can be uh okay your
time is up now my answer is and it will
force your model to respond
and then if you think about it
um
your model gives tokens in its reasoning
chain but
models may think on some other on some
other space maybe not in the language
space. So there is uh also a line of
work around having some continuous
thoughts
uh basically having this uh thinking
token actually not be tokens but be
hidden representations that can be more
meaningful but also more compressed. Uh
so you have a bunch of papers on this.
So there's one that I that we linked uh
which is actually from 2024 but I think
even like a few days ago I also saw
another paper on that. So it's a very
much research active area of research
and
I guess just like that I guess we saw
that the way that we want to scale our
model is with RL.
I guess is everyone convinced of that?
Did I convince you well with those
arguments or does anyone have any
questions on this? And I guess here I
want you to take away to have a takeaway
which is we want to use RL
to incentivize our model to think more
if we start from scratch meaning we
don't have reasoning chains.
So is everyone good with this?
Yeah.
Yeah. Kind of. Yeah. Okay. So I'll take
this as a yes. So now we're going to see
the algorithm that we use
to perform that oral step and you may
have heard this acronym a lot. So this
uh algorithm that we will see is called
GRPO
and GRPO has been released in 2024
and it has been kind of the go-to RL
algorithm for all these reasoning tasks
or for these reasoning training tasks.
So what is GRPO?
So, GRPO stands for group relative
policy optimization
and
it is a an RL algorithm which very much
like PO aims to do these two things we
talked about. So the first one is to
maximize advantages.
And if you remember, advantage is
something that tells you whether what
you're producing as an answer is better
than what you would expect.
So
this is the first part. And then the
second part is that you do not want
to deviate too much from either the old
model which is the model at the previous
RL iteration
or the base model
which is the model at SFT stage.
So GRPO is also doing the same thing as
PO in that sense. But then there's a key
difference
and that difference lies in how it
computes the advantage.
So if you remember
PO
estimated the advantage by taking the
rewards which is at the completion
level. So you know you have your prompt
and you have a response a full response
and then based on those two elements you
have a reward.
So what PO did was take that into
consideration along with something else
that it was training jointly at training
time which was called the value
function.
And the value function objective was to
try to predict what that reward was if
we were to continue generating the
tokens following the policy.
And if you remember the advantage here
is actually in the case of PO was
something that we obtained based on a
very complex formula that we did not see
actually but that's called a generalized
advantage estimation that is a method
to estimate those advantage
and the big limitation with that was
that you had to train a value function
jointly with your policy. So this was
this big bottleneck.
And in contrast to that, GRPO says,
well, we're not going to do that.
We're going to take a completion.
We're going to compute its reward
and we're going to compare it with the
average of rewards
of completions for that same prompt.
So I'll give you an example. So let's
suppose we have a math problem.
So what we're saying here is we're going
to generate multiple completions for
that same prompt
and for each prompt
and completion and the prompt is shared.
So for each completion,
we're going to measure I guess a
relative
um measure of the reward for that
completion and all the other rewards of
the other completions.
So this will give us an idea of how much
better or how much worse is it from I
guess the rest of the group. And so this
is going to be our advantage.
So the big benefit here is that we do
not use value functions. We do not use
that. The only thing we do is
we sample not just one but
[clears throat] multiple completions in
order to compute the average of the
rewards of the group.
Does this make sense?
Oh yeah.
So what what would you do instead?
So the question is why would you do
that? Well, the traditional RL
algorithms just for reference they have
been developed before all these LLMs
became a thing. So for instance, PPU was
a method that I believe is from 2017.
So these quantities they may make a lot
of sense in some setups but maybe not in
the language world. And I guess here the
idea is let's try to think of something
that tells you how good your completion
is just in the relative sense. But here
I guess what the authors want to do is
to not have to have this very expensive
joint model that they have to train and
think of another relative way of doing
that. So I think that's the high level
intuition and I guess here the idea is
let's just sample multiple times and see
how one response is comparing to the
others and then use that as some kind of
baseline to to put this reward into
context. So for instance, you may have a
math problem that's kind of easy and if
you have a high reward for that one,
maybe it's because the problem was easy
to start with.
But if you have let's say um very hard
problem, if you have the correct answer,
then you want to make sure you're
incentivizing your model to upweight
those those tokens much more because
if you find a good solution, it's a good
solution to a hard problem. So you want
to somehow bake that in into your
advantage. So that's kind of the
intuition.
So, GRPO was developed a year ago and a
year ago, you know, LLMs were
everywhere. So, this is also taking into
consideration,
I guess, what LLMs are incentivized to
do in some sense. Um, so yeah, I would
thinking that way.
Does that help? Cool. Cool.
Any other question on this?
Well, don't worry if you have questions
because we will have a walk through of
exactly how it works. So, here we're
going to go through the exact same thing
but illustrate it.
So, in the GRPO case, we're taking a
query
and we're passing that through our
policy model which is our LLM that we're
trying to train.
And here what we said was we want to
generate not one
but multiple completions. Let's suppose
G g completions
and each of these query completions. So
you have G such pairs
you pass them through the reward model
that gives you G rewards.
And what you want is to compute the
advantage which puts all these rewards
into their context. So we saw it was uh
basically the reward minus the average.
But it's actually not exactly that. So
it's reward minus the average over the
standard deviation of those rewards.
This is how they defined it.
By the way, we will see that this it may
not be the the best way to do it, but
we'll see that in a second.
And we use those advantage those
advantages to then tune our policy
model.
And
while we do that we of course don't want
to deviate too much for from the
reference model. So we have the scale
divergence term as well over here.
So that is GRPO
and we're going to see right now exactly
how this worked with PO.
So with PO if you remember you have your
prompt you have your query
you pass that through your policy model
and you only only have one completion
and you pass your prompt and your
completion. So this pair you pass it
through the reward model
and this gives you a reward for that
whole completion.
Now there's one thing we did not see
last time which is more of a
implementation detail
but we also have a kale divergence term
that is comparing the probability of
each token with the probability of the
token for from the reference model.
And from an implementation standpoint,
we also typically incorporate that in
the rewards.
So we have something like a per token
rewards where only the last token has
the reward of the whole completion, but
then everyone has also a kale divergence
term. So that one is not super important
here to like have in mind but it's just
good to know that people implement it
that way.
So once you have those rewards you also
have a value function
that this one is per token.
This one tries to quantify the rewards
if you were to continue generating the
rest of the sequence following the
policy.
And we saw there is this method that
we're not going to see that is called
generalized advantage estimation that
takes in those two quantities and
computes the advantage. You can think of
it as some complicated formula
and you have your advantage that you use
to tune the policy
and that's it which is complicated
compared to this one. So GRPO you use
advantages that are a result of this
group computation but then PO you have
an advantage that is a result of
rewards
and the value function which is per
token.
Yeah.
Cool. Um
so what are the models at stake here? So
here we have some models that we use
that are quote unquote frozen that are
not the ones that we train. So for GRPO
we have the reference model that we do
the K divergence on and then we have the
reward model which we trained in the
past
and the same is the case for PPU.
Now one thing to note is that in the
reasoning case
we are actually not training a reward
model because we know how to tell
whether a solution is correct or not. We
actually have a verifiable reward. So in
the reasoning case we're actually not
having any reward model at all. It's the
same for both.
Now what is different is the models that
we train. So in the gRPO case we only
train the policy model whereas in the PO
case we train the policy model and the
value function the value model
and this is the key difference.
Okay so until now we've seen only uh
drawings and illustrations.
Uh so let's see some math. So you have
the GRPO loss function at the top and
the PO loss function at the bottom. They
look scary,
but we're going to see together some
similarities and some differences.
So what is one similarity?
Both of them they operate on the ratio
of the probability of the current policy
and the probability of the old policy.
So that's the first point in common.
The second point in common is that both
of them
they try to keep the updates
within some region
like not too uh wide and they do that
with the clipping mechanism that we saw
last lecture.
So I recommend that you just like go
through these charts that we saw
together. you know, when the advantage
is positive, how uh the loss looks like
uh and when the advantage is negative.
Uh so this clipping function just allows
you to not make updates that are too
big, that are too white.
But now, okay, what is different?
So in the gRPO case
the kale divergence is actually
something that is explicitly part
of the objective function
whereas for the PO case the scale
divergence is typically part of the
advantage.
So this is more of a technical detail
but
like a few minutes ago I had mentioned
that
from an implementation standpoint we
typically incorporate the K divergence
within the rewards that are considered
in the advantage computation.
So that's one
one difference and then the second
difference is the way we compute
advantages.
So we saw that GRPO we typically
compute rewards for each completions and
then we compare them with the other
completions from the group. Whereas for
PPO we use the rewards and the value
models.
So far so good.
I think I have some other things I want
to talk about, but before that I just
want to kind of open the floor if anyone
has any questions. This is very
technical by the way, a very technical,
probably the hardest part of the whole
class. So, it's completely normal to I
guess take some time to digest that. And
if no one has any questions, I actually
see this as more of an alarm for myself
because this is maybe uh I don't know.
So let let me know if there's any
any questions on this and uh yeah
absolutely no problem to have any kind
of questions.
Is everything super clear?
Super clear. Okay. So just tell yourself
that these algorithms
they're just there to tune your model in
the RL stage.
PPU is heavily used in the preference
tuning framework where you try to tune
your model to align it with human
preferences and GRPO is commonly used
for this reasoning based training.
So I think if you tell yourself that
then it's something and then the second
thing you need to tell yourself is GRPO
differs from PO
in that GRPO does not need a value
function.
it actually computes its uh advantages
by comparing the rewards with respect to
other completions
and then the PPO it takes in the reward
it takes in the value and then compares
the two to get the advantage.
So if this is making sense I think this
is already a very good thing. So is this
making sense?
Yeah. Okay,
cool. Uh, I would also recommend to just
rewatch the recording. So, we're
recording this. Um, this is, you know,
very heavy and, uh, can be technical.
So, yeah, just like re-watching it a few
times, I think, can help. So, we have 11
minutes before giving it to Shervin. And
what we're going to see now is some
extensions of the GRPO work that was
done last year that people have done in
the past uh few months. So this research
is going back to early 2025 but it has
gained enough traction for us to talk
about it in this class.
So if you remember what I mentioned in
the beginning of the lecture,
reasoning tokens are being charged to
you as a user. So you don't want to pay
a lot, right? You don't want to pay too
much. So you want your model to do what
you want, but you do not want it to
generate too much so that you're getting
charged for it.
and also from the provider sides I guess
it's much better to be more efficient.
So there is an incentive to see what we
can optimize from the output length
perspective.
So if you see the training of these
models,
one thing that you notice is that as you
train it in the RL stage, the output
increases in length.
So here this graph shows as a function
of the RL step the average length per
response.
So you see like from an empirical
perspective that the answer that the LLM
is outputting is getting longer and
longer.
And this is mainly coming from the
reasoning chain that is being more and
more sophisticated.
And when you compare this graph with
respect to how the performance of the
model improves,
you see that you know this increase here
in length
is actually correlated with an increase
in performance.
And you might say okay it's good.
But then there comes a stage over here
where the performance so it's on the on
the left. the performance of your model
tends to stabili stabilize,
but then your output length still
continues increasing.
And so a lot of people have looked at
these charts and they're like, okay,
there's something going on.
So here what we're going to do is to
look at this phenomenon
and see how people have tried to
mitigate it.
So little warning this is also a little
bit technical so please bear with me
there is one formula that I will try to
explain to the best that I can but there
is some amount of math
so in order in order to understand
what's happening
we need to look at the GRPO loss and the
GRPO loss is the one that I just
mentioned here seems like a very
complicated formula but it it's not
really a complicated one. I'm going to
just explain in plain terms what this
means. So J of GRPO J means objective
function. So the objective function of
GRPO
is to maximize
this quantity which is a function of how
much your model changes with respect to
the old one. So it's these ratios that
you see in the in the slide and you have
this clipping mechanism that prevents
your updates from being too wide.
And then you have uh the kale divergence
on the right which prevents your model
from being too far from the base model,
the reference model.
And then you have these summations here.
And the summations here, they correspond
to you going through that process for
all completions in your group. Because
remember, if you have a prompt, you
sample it several times, you have
several completions.
And then you do that for every token of
your output.
So here the first summation is over the
indices of your group. The second
summation is over the indices
that are with respect to the token
number in your sequence.
And so here I guess let's just kind of
think for a second. Okay, if we were to
swap I'm not sure if you see uh what I
did here. I just swapped the one over
length of output number I. I just
swapped it here.
I'm going to explain why I did that. So
if you look at this,
this is a factor that is only a function
of which output you're in.
So if you're in a very long output,
this will be one over a very long
output, it will be a small number,
right? If it's in it's a short output,
it's going to be one over a short
number. It's going to be a big number.
Right? And the term on the right on the
right of this is token specific.
So in other words, the contribution of a
token with respect to the objective
function
depends on the output that it is in.
So if the token is in a short sentence,
it's going to have a higher weight,
bigger weight than in a longer sentence
until now. Is everyone agreeing with me?
Yeah.
Okay. So with that being said, I'm just
going to rephrase what I just said.
If you are in a short sentence,
your weight will be bigger than if
you're in the bigger sentence.
Right?
Now,
let's try to think about this in terms
of of the advantage.
If you are in the case of a token being
in an output that is of advantage that
is positive that means that
we would want to upweight the
probability of this token happening
again much more for short sentences as
opposed to longer ones.
And at the same time,
you want when the advantage is negative.
So it's not you want, it's just that
this formulation
makes tokens that are in short outputs
be downweighted even more
compared to when they're in a long
output.
And so this is the problem. This is a
bad incentive because what you're
telling your model is if you have a
short bad sentence, it is worse than if
you have a long bad sentence.
So that's the idea here. So I'm just
going to just rephrase what we said
until now. The fact of dividing by the
length of the output is incentivizing
your model to downweight even more
tokens. If the same tokens in a short
output, it will it will be downweighted
even more than if it's in a long output.
So in other words,
what you're going to do is to prefer
longer bad outputs as opposed to shorter
shorter bad outputs.
And this is what people are
hypothesizing that is making the output
length
bigger and bigger. And we're going to
see that in a second. So what people did
was do something about this. So this one
over length of O people wanted to do
something about it.
So there is one paper that came out in
March DPO quite a popular paper now that
actually equalizes these token level
contributions
and so here this normalization factor is
now common to all tokens
and there is another paper that's called
uh so I think it's GRPO done rights but
it's Dr. GRPO. So I'm not sure how you
you pronounce it, but that paper
actually proposes to remove the factor
altogether.
And when you do that,
if you compare the GRPO
versus the one that equalizes the token
level contributions,
you see that if you plot reward as a
function of output length,
your model will stop increasing its
length again and again.
So if you actually look deeper
um samples that are correct
are actually having a length that is
matching with the GRP1 but for incorrect
solutions
here the corrected policy is having an
average length that's that's much lower
than the ones from GRPO. So that's the
bottom right chart
and that is actually making so this
adjustment is actually making the
intended
um consequence.
So that's one very important I think
very important one important
modification that people typically apply
and I'm looking at the time uh in one
minute I will just tell you about some
other modifications that people do. So
there is a modification with respect to
the standard deviation
uh that is within the advantage formula
that biases towards uh like
in terms of the difficulty of the
problem because if let's suppose you
have a very hard problem
most of your completions will be let's
say failures and so your standard
deviation will not be super large.
So this can cause problems.
And then there is another modification
that people typically also consider
which is having different epsilons.
And if you remember that epsilon
influences how much you're able to
change the policy from one iteration to
another.
And the idea here is that if the
probability of your token is very low,
it is kind of unfair to just give it a
small epsilon to grow because this
epsilon is multiplied, right? So I'm
just going to write that down and then
it's going to be uh shervin
uh where is this? Okay. So,
so we actually want
the ratio of
pi over pi all to be roughly you know
in between those bounds roughly.
So in other words it's 1 + epsilon * pi
of old. Right? So if this one is very
low,
you cannot really
change your value too much.
And you don't want to have an epsilon
that's too high because you don't want
big probabilities to suddenly go to
zero.
So you want to introduce an asymmetry
between the lower and the upper bounds.
Cool.
So this was a lot. Any questions on
this?
Okay, we're running short on time. We're
going to have uh some time after the
lecture in case you have any questions.
And uh with that, I'm going to give it
to Shervin.
Thank you for covering all the hard
parts. Now it's going to be a bit easier
because we're going to see how all of
this comes together. Um and in
particular we're going to focus at the
deepseek papers and exactly how they
used all these techniques that Afin
covered into uh building these reasoning
models.
So what we saw at previous lectures what
quote unquote traditional LLMs. So you
started from a pre-trained base model
where you did a next token prediction on
a bunch of text of the internet and then
out of this you proceeded to do your
alignments which was composed of SFT and
then RL. So like not the reasoning style
RL but like the regular one and then the
SFT was u like instruction tuning and
we're going to see how these newer
models are being trained and I think the
example of the deepseek R1 paper is a
great one because they go into multiple
stages. first into showing how powerful
can the RL stage be if you apply the
verifiable rewards that Afen mentioned
and then based on the observations
of like the performance that you get out
of it how to deise a full pipeline of
getting a super powerful model that they
called R1.
So yeah, respectively a proof of concept
and then a full reasoning model. Does
that sound good?
Okay, great. So now let's start with the
recipe that uh DeepSc folks use for the
R10 model. So they first started with um
like a pre-trained model uh like trained
on next token prediction on uh like the
latest architectures with all the bells
and whistles. So you recall from
previous lectures we talked about uh
mixture of experts. So they have this
and they reuse a trick called multi-
latent attenu attention MLA that they
had introduced in deepseek v2 and we had
talked about it uh as well you can see
in their architecture they use a porm in
their transformer blocks so they have um
like a typical baslm so they perform uh
next token prediction on it and then
this is where the fun starts so Instead
of going ahead with an alignment
strategy that consists of SFT, they just
start with this pre-trained model just
trained on next token prediction and
that hasn't seen any supervision so far
and they apply the technique that Afin
just mentioned
um on uh reasoning data. So they look at
rewards and all they incentivize the
model to do is to um increase the
rewards based on the output uh like
output answer that the model gives as
well as formatting. So if you have your
like thoughts think tokens that I've
mentioned then uh like the reward on the
formatting side would be uh would be
given
and the paper gives exactly the
templates over which they trained uh the
model. So it's a very simple one. um you
have like the first sentences that set
up the stage that say you know hey
you're discussing with the user you're
an assistant and then the reward uh that
I mentioned regarding formatting is
explained in plain text so it says
whatever you want to think about just do
it but put it into think um into think
boxes
uh and then uh you know once you're
ready to give your answer you should
wrap it under like an answer um
basically answer um blocks
and what you see here in red is what you
replace by the sample prompts and uh and
then at the end you give the opportunity
to the model to respond.
Does that make sense?
Okay, great. And I'm going to show you
again a graph that Afin had showed. So
it was uh done on R10 where they said
that without any prior supervision just
having this as a reward increases scores
on uh reasoning based benchmarks. So
this one I think is on AIM. It's like
math one. And you see that the accuracy
improves over time.
And you might think, you know, all is
solved. It's great. No SFT and we
already have the best performance
possible. Well, uh, not so easy because
the authors when they looked at the
reasoning chains, they saw some issues
with it of two kinds. So first when the
model was thinking about um like was
emitting distinct tokens sometimes it
would mix languages
and you had also syntax issues and uh
you could hypothesize that this might be
the case because you haven't really seen
any strong supervision uh just before
that and you give the opportunity to the
model to optimize
anything the anything it wants but it
doesn't really have uh like as a
background like a strong supervision
signal to anchor on. So this is one key
challenge that we're going to see
together how they try to resolve it.
Um does the R10 process make sense?
Okay, awesome. Uh so now that we have
seen what R10 tried to prove the the
fact that with RL only you can get
reasoning level performance now we're
going to see how to adjust the
challenges that we have seen into a full
uh pipeline. So that one they call it R1
and they start from the same um the same
basis. So they start from a v3 base
which is the pre-trained model that uh
deepseek had trained during their v3
paper. So it was the non-reasoning
version of of this model. uh so they
start from it and then instead of
starting directly to doing the RL um
stage that we have discussed they try to
align it in a way that will nicely
um like try to alleviate the issues we
have seen. So it starts from what they
called as cold cold start data. They
generated
u like coots
and um so the during the r zero stage
and these coots sometimes had issues. So
they used humans to rewrite some of
these so that all these coots are
compliant when it comes to formatting
you know language consistency
and then they used these pairs prompts
and then rewritten prompts
as data to train uh SFT on it. So uh you
know and I think there was no number
given on um on the number of samples
given to to that stage but uh from the
warning of the paper it could have been
several orders of magnitude less than
some of the other stages that we have
seen. So potentially in the O of case
of of input output pairs.
Okay. So now that we have this stage
ready, uh they continued with the RL
stage that uh R10 would do and then
we're going to explore
um you know the the reward function that
they used. So not only we have this uh
verifiable reward based on the response
of the reasoning model uh output that we
wanted to have. Uh but also we have the
formatting reward and there is something
new that they introduced as well to
counter the effect of having poor
readability in their uh in their
thoughts. There was something called a
language consistency reward where they
use um a very simple uh like huristic to
assess whether the model indeed doesn't
mix languages. So I believe it was the
ratio of the tokens in the target
language in the outputed chain. So they
just put that in order to maximize uh
the amount of correct language tokens.
Um
okay great. And after this first pass of
RL they continued on with SFT with a
very interesting uh strategy. So they do
it as like a larger scale than the cold
start one. And now they mix both
reasoning and then non-reasoning data uh
in order to make the model useful to the
span of cases that you as a user might
solicitate the model for.
And regarding non-reasoning data, they
uh recycled some of the data that was
used for their non-reasoning version of
the model for V3. So about 200k uh pairs
and it covers the domains that we have
mentioned during the instruction tuning
lecture. So like a broad array of
topics.
uh and then what they did is that they
added to it a lot of pairs that are
directed towards reasoning. So the ratio
was 3:1 and then the reasoning ones uh
were um generating uh with a method
called rejection sampling. So what they
did is that they um they took some
prompts covering these reasoning based
uh fields and they used the model that
had been trained so far to generate a
response and then based on the output
and on some with some judge they would
keep some answers and reject others such
that the resulting uh data sets would be
of very high quality. So this is what
they call by rejection sampling. It's uh
yeah just a fact of filtering out any uh
answers that are not you know perfect.
And the reason why I guess they did it
automatically with like some LLM judges
and so on is like given the scale of the
data and you know these were u huristics
that that worked pretty nice uh on that.
You had a question? No. Uh, okay.
So once they were done with that, they
uh went on to a last stage that was one
that you might u that might make you
think about the ones that u occur in
non-reasoning model training pipelines.
Uh so they mix this time not only
reasoning data but also non-reasoning
ones. So for the reasoning data you know
same kind of reward as we have seen but
on the non-reasoning one um you try to
align the model on characteristics that
make an LLM a helpful assistant and a
harmless one. So you have this
helpfulness and harmlessness
components of that uh part of the
reward. And the harmlessness was a
reward that was applied on the whole uh
tokens that were outputed. So not just
the output because you want the chain of
thoughts in the think uh section of the
answer to be um to be harmless indeed.
And then the helpfulness one was uh more
focused on on what you saw at the user
at the user level.
Okay, great. And just to give some idea
of the results they got. Um so first you
notice that on uh reasoning based um on
reasoning based benchmarks you have two
clusters of result that appear you have
all these non-reasoning based models
that have uh some performance and then
the reasoning based ones have
unsurprisingly uh like reasoning uh like
a performance that is much higher. And
then the second thing that we observe
out of these results is that uh R1 was
pretty competitive with respect to
closed source models that claim to be
reasoning based and it was a pretty um
pretty interesting uh you know moment as
Afin had mentioned uh to reproduce such
um like such a level of of performance.
Okay, great. So I want to finish this
lecture on a interesting note of you
know let's say you don't have a 600b
at your disposal let's say you have a
smaller model but you want to have the
capabilities of this large uh reasoning
model you know how would you go about it
so I just want to give you a reminder of
how we had dealt with this topic a few
lectures ago when we talked about
distillation
So at that time we were just talking
about pre-training and then instruction
tuning where the data we were dealing
with was fixed. So for example for next
token prediction you know the text you
want the model to fit on. For SFT you
have fixed pairs. You know exactly what
you want to learn. And what you did was
look for each next token prediction at
the output probability distribution of a
teacher model. And on your student
model, instead of fitting a hard label
of the next token, you fitted instead
the whole probability distribution of
the teacher model in order to distill
the knowledge quote unquote of that
teacher model into the student model. Do
you all remember that? Yep.
So now u you know how could you go ahead
with this in this in this case? So here
as you have seen we don't necessarily
have SFT pairs based on reasoning out of
the box. So if you want to distill the
knowledge of a teacher model here uh the
authors have gone through an interesting
route that is still called distillation
but it's another flavor of it. So we use
the teacher model here R1 to generate
some sample responses and including
think thinking tokens.
So this is something that is done uh
like you know offline and then in a
second stage you run uh this SFT and fit
a smaller model on your distilled
uh on your distilled model which is
typically like much less weights than
than the teacher one. So instead of
fitting a probability distribution over
the next token, you just fit the entire
sequence. you just try to predict the
same sequence of tokens that the teacher
has outputed.
Does this um framing of distillation
here make sense? Yeah.
Okay. Awesome. And I'm going to conclude
here by looking at the results. So you
can see that the results once again are
very competitive with uh closed source
alternatives that claim to be uh like a
smaller version of a reasoning model. So
for example 01 mini you can see that the
numbers here are competitive with
respect to that. And then you could also
wonder but why did you go through the
trouble of um of like just distilling
when you could just like do the same RL
techniques?
Well actually uh the authors have seen
that at a smaller uh size level
distilling the knowledge is more uh
efficient in terms of performance than
uh directly learning from scratch.
All good.
And with that, have a great weekend.